nick castellanos in uni the reds offense
was the best in baseball in his absence
but he returns with the top average in
the national league second best in the
majors the ball in terms of starting
pitching tonight gets placed in the
hands of sonny gray he is the perfect
person i think to lead off this series
against this pittsburgh pirate team this
is a series that i feel that the reds
know that they should win hoy park leads
off one two
definitely went on the high heat sonny
gray with a kick here's kevin newman now
and he hits this line drive base hitting
the right took one hop on the infield
dirt and then rolls into right or one
out opposite field single and now brian
reynolds will stride to the plate runner
goes
pitch call to strike throw down no
chance at a tag
farmer had to hop to bring it in newman
the 2-2 pitch swing gonna miss struck
him out he chased the curve ball down
and out of the zone there and sonny gray
has his second strike out of this first
inning he faces keep ryan hayes chopped
up the middle it'll be fielded by india
shortstop side of the bag the throw in
time be bryan hayes out it'll go 4-3
and the side is retired now will crow on
the hill for the 17th time this season
his 16th start rookie versus rookie in
india having a fine season 284 average
11 homers
goes fastball in india rocks it
clobbered to left field jonathan ending
it to the upper deck his fourth home run
in six games
his third lead-off shot that kid is
so
so impressive get a home run from india
and now a hit by pitch of winker
let's listen to this
for the first time in almost three weeks
nick castellanos
and he'll take his walk
and that brings joey votto to the plate
one all his line caught by nakowski
they're gonna double up jesse winker way
off the second base bag well that came
in nice and handy timely now that's an
absolute rocket right at somebody that
ends up getting you two outs great
worked around a single in the first
inning gregory polanco
swing and a miss struck him out breaking
ball city
against polanco three different
locations on three breaking balls strike
one strike two and strike three
gray pops them up
farmer in the outfield grass one two
three inning farmers aboard with a lead
off single here in the second inning the
batter is tyler naquin
grounded
defoe can't handle farmer and slid he
has to hold at second base that's going
to be an error on defo his fifth of the
year but his first and second base
two aboard okay eugenio suarez batting
eighth first time he has started in the
eighth position since june of 2015
[Applause]
cracks it to deep right center
perhaps his best at bat
of the season that was a great at bat
and a great swing letting the ball
travel that's it geno second and third
two outs and here's joey votto
high in the air deep right center field
gone
bottle tie suarez for the team lead in
dingers his 22nd and he is your outright
rbi leader in the reds clubhouse
cash
money and the reds are sending 11 to the
plate they scored six times and now
leads seven to nothing
sonny gray sticks the fastball
on the edge inside will crow has one hit
in 21 at bats this season
swing of the miss
first time through the nine sonny gray
with five strikeouts well here's sunny
gray sunny one for one tonight
sunny gray opposite way splashes down
sunny gray
had one hit on the season and he's got
two knocks tonight that's the first
career multi-hit game that brings kee
bryan hayes the plate and a swing and a
miss hayes chased a breaking ball in the
dirt it gets away from stevenson but he
gets to it quickly to throw out
hayes at first strikeout goes two three
two gone in the fourth
and gray's got seven strikeouts graves
only allows one hit a kevin newman
single in the first inning and a four
pitch walk to jacob stallings the pirate
catcher with one out in the fifth this
ball lined to right field and that'll
drop in for a hit
and into the corner it goes
for extra bases
wilmer defoe doubles jacob stallings to
third phillip evans will be the pirate
pinch hitter here
well if that leads him to be safe we'll
take it yes
pirates are on the board pinch hit rbi
single for phillip evans here's hoyt
park
chop tovato
starts in run down ignited and suarez
was laid to break and cover vato had the
window and suarez stood frozen at first
off of third base and now its base is
loaded i think the assumption was the
ball was going to go to first base well
now it's kevin newman who is the hardest
man to strike out of the majors
oh diving try by farmer everyone's going
to be safe keep the line moving and
kevin newman does this that now seven to
two reds the bases remain loaded and the
batter is brian reynolds
on the ground slowly hit and farmer
able to get one evans is in seven three
two down parked to third brian hayes
bats
that gets through key brian hayes drives
in a run
reynolds will head to third it's seven
to four
the pirates are right back in this one
with a four run fifth inning kyle farmer
is three for three tonight and now tyler
naquin is the batter high fly ball
center field deep reynolds is back to
the track at the wall leaping up and he
made the catch reynolds just robbed them
of a home run
jumping up at the right center field
fence
brian reynolds
two days after gregory polanco robs a
player of a home run in milwaukee
reynolds does it here in cincinnati put
that thing in platinum runners at first
and second base and unfortunately for
the reds the tying run comes to the
plate and that is key brian hayes
broken back to farmer underhand feed
india on the first double play
well jeff hoffman gets the job done yet
again inducing the ground ball to
farmer
india and michael gibbons gets his first
save chance as a red trying to set a new
outright franchise record with ten
different reds pitchers recording a save
in a single season and two men are out
in the night
set high in the air right center field
castainos on the track makes the catch
the reds set a new record
ten different men have saved the game
and they are seven over 500 for the
first time since july 13
2014.